observation of nature finds the notion
realized in inorganic nature laws whose
moments are things which at the same
time have the character of abstractions
but this notion is not a simplicity that
is reflected into itself the life of
organic nature on the other hand is only
this intro reflected simplicity the
antithesis within it of the universal
and individual does not sunder itself in
the essence of this life itself the
essence is not the genus which in its
undifferentiated element would be self
sundered and self moved and at the same
time would be for itself
undifferentiated in its antithesis
observation finds this free notion whose
universality contains just as absolutely
within it developed individuality only
in the notion which itself exists as
notion that is in self-consciousness
in paragraph 298 we're now entering a
new portion of Hegel's phenomenology
it's not a very long portion but there's
an important transition that's taking
place here and the the next sub portion
that's going to be following is closely
connected with it and and you might say
using it as a springboard the section
that includes the famous physiognomies
and phrenology which people by the way
is not endorsing he's actually attacking
those pseudo-sciences in his discussion
so here we notice that we move from
observation of nature through in the
previous section observation of organic
nature and now we're talking about
observation of self-consciousness and we
want to see why that transition is
taking place and it really is beginning
in its paragraph we're going to talk
about that in a moment I do want to
signal the difference between this
section and the section that follows so
this is observation of
self-consciousness in its purity and in
its relation to external actualities you
don't get in a Hegelian perspective you
don't get things fully detached totally
separated from the environment and the
observing or engaging interaction
consciousness that is is working with
them that would be a very abstract way
of looking at things and Hegel is trying
to move away from the abstract not
because the abstract is necessarily
false in and of itself but because when
placed in contra position to actual
living things or human culture or
whatever it is that we're trying to
observe the abstract makes itself false
by pretending to be what the thing
really is so well this section is like I
said some consciousness in its purity
that's why Hegel is going to begin
talking about logical and psychological
laws and whether they apply er can hold
or really are in laws at all the next
section the one that includes the
physiognomies and phrenology is
observation of the relation of
self-consciousness to its immediate
actuality and what is the difference
there well as we're going to see the
individual and the universal are going
to be playing off against each other
throughout this section in this section
we're looking for what really is
universal what we can say about all
human minds now if you think about
modern philosophy the way that that
typically took place was not by you know
even among the empiricists doing a kind
of you know inductive generalization by
looking at many many people that didn't
happen at first if you look at you know
say Locke or or Hume or people like that
they make just as much reference to
reflection to looking at one's own
experience and using that as sort of the
model as do the so called continental
rationalist like to Cartmell brush
Spinoza live that's all these people and
these are leading up to Hayden's
position a bit after that we're going to
see a lot of attempts to empirically say
something you know an inquiry that
that's being carried out inductively
about the totality of human beings or in
general not just human beings in the
world but human beings in a specific
place like say Germany or England but
that has a lot of practice so let's talk
about what's happening in this paragraph
well Hegel begins by saying observation
of nature finds the notion realized in
inorganic nature that sounds kind of
strange doesn't it finds the notion
realized well in what he means there is
it's been trying to understand the
notion by way of
organic nature in which we have a
universal and an individual who are
connected with each other you know and
we can say that you know whatever salt
we want to look at or you know whatever
other chemical compound we want to look
at we can make sense of it the universal
just is sort of the type of the
individual just is sort of the instance
right and the universal is abstract and
the individual is just something
perceived there's no life to it we don't
expect life in the inorganic nature but
this means that it's something that is
merely an object for consciousness it
does have an in itself but then in
itself doesn't have the same sort of
value as it does for the smallest living
thing so he knows animate says these
moments have the character of
abstractions but this notion is not a
simplicity that is reflected into itself
where do we have to go for that well
that is when we're talking about organic
nature the organic nature is something
that has a tell us and it's tell us is
in part to maintain itself in existence
it has a kind of fluidity as we've
talked about it is essence a certain
degree of freedom that's going to be a
very important concept in this entire
section so you know zombunny says the
life of organic nature is only this
intro reflected simplicity if it's the
inner all the ways we've been trying to
find the outer you know in all these
permutations in the past section he goes
on he says the antithesis within an
individual and universal does not sunder
itself in the essence of life itself
there is an antithesis there's an
opposition a dynamic relationship
between the universal and the individual
within the organic being now the
question is well where are we going to
find this and Hegel says well do we get
this in terms of genus we talked quite a
bit about them in the last section so
the essence is not the genus which in
its undifferentiated elements would be
self-centered itself moved at the same
time would be for itself on
differentiate
synthesis where do we look at some
observation finds this free notion free
cuts three free but Griffith whose
universality contains just as absolutely
within it developed individuality
developed individuality and that's a key
thing there we're no longer tithing just
about were in isms we're talking about
human beings remember how in towards the
end of the last section Hegel started
talking about world history and spirit
and all of that and said that life by
itself just pure living things don't
have a history human beings do now we're
getting to the distinctively human so he
says observation finds us free notion
only in the notion which itself exists
as notion there's a little misprint
there act that says in Miller's
translation that should be asked this is
self consciousness grasping oneself as
an individual and yet also as a
universal and vice-versa
it is a universal trait of human being
to not only be individual but also to be
universal so what does all that mean
well we're going to see this played out
about and the paragraphs yet to come
when observation now turns in upon
itself and directs its attention to the
notion existing as free notion it finds
to begin with the laws of thought this
into the duality which thought is in its
own self is the abstract movement of the
negative a movement wholly retracted
into simplicity and the laws are outside
of reality to say that they have no
reality means in general nothing else
than that they lack truth they are
indeed not supposed to be the entire
truth but still formal truth but what is
purely formal without any reality is a
mere figment of thought or pure
abstraction without that internal
division which would be nothing else but
the content on the other hand however
since they are laws of pure thought and
pure thought is intrinsically universal
and therefore a knowledge which
immediately contains being and there in
all reality these laws are absolute
notions and are inseparably the
essential principles both of form and of
things since imminent self-moving
universality is the sundered simple
notion the latter thus has in itself a
content and one which is all content
only not a sensuous being it is a
content which is neither in
contradiction with the form nor is
separated from it rather it is
essentially the form itself for the
latter is nothing else but the universal
dividing itself into its pure moments
what we see in paragraph 299 is Hagel
introducing and grappling with one of
the first dualities not dualisms but but
dualities that is running throughout
this entire section of observation of
self-consciousness then in this case
between the thoughts and reality or
we're being and how the formal and the
content are connected as well in that
that duality so we've really got to do
Alaniz here that are paired off with
each other
Hegel who begins by talking about
observation of notion as free notion
what do we mean there so observation of
the concept and what was the concept
well radula it was being organic nature
than it was organic nature and then it
was what free self consciousness the
human being the notion per se embodied
in human beings no longer just in
Beatles or amoeba or whatever else we
have but something that you really have
a history that can have culture that can
have development and he says this leads
us to what he's calling here the laws of
thought now at this point I think for
modern audience then is a lot of
matically going to bring up you know the
ideas of logic and because you know
we've got this definition floating out
there logic and the discipline that
studies the laws of thought but what
Hugh was talking about is not just logic
and by that he doesn't just mean formal
logic anyway what we teach in you know
contemporary academia has logic but also
psychology the laws of thought are
supposed to not just tell us how we
ought to think but help us understand
how human beings do in fact think and
what the necessities involved in that
however complex those necessities may be
to articulate would be so the question
then is how are thought
Allen a connected together in these laws
Hegel any said is going to take a double
perspective in this paragraph he starts
off by talking about a kind of failure
thought he says here we go the
individuality which Splott is in its own
self is the abstract movement of the
negative movement wholly retracted into
simplicity and the laws are outside of
reality so when we think about thought
you know we we have this word that we
use and we use it as a kind of universal
but where does thought really take place
it is individual this is something that
we haven't thought much or haven't
thought enough about the nature of
thought its slippery
condition and so we're gonna play around
with this a lot in paragraphs yet to
come we don't unpack all of this right
now but insofar as it's being considered
as individual it remains abstract and
the laws of thought which are informal
aspect are not penetrating to the
reality that they're supposed to be
grappled with Hagen goes on and talks
about this the laws are outside of
reality he says to say that they have no
reality means in general that they lack
truth
so in this failure to get any further
you know towards reality there is a gap
there is a lack there is something
missing there and you know as we know in
the Galilean universe wherever there's
something so negative there's always
something coming in to fill it in with
what with content so now we look at the
relationship between form and content
which is going to play a major role in
future paragraphs he says they are
indeed not supposed to be the entire
truth but still formal truth when we
tell you this is where you know think
about what we do in a logic class people
will often get quite upset when they
find out that you know what they learn
in a logic class doesn't immediately
translate to the
reality of social existence and the
real-life arguments that we make towards
each other and in relation to each other
in the context they say oh this is no
good and then the logician comes along
and says hey I wasn't trying to provide
you with that I was merely trying to
provide you with sort of the formal
conditions for reasoning or inference or
something like that and so Hegel says
yeah this is one way in which we do in
fact understand this so the laws are
just supposed to be formal and that's
supposed to be formal truth well that's
a prop Hegel says whatever is purely
formal without any reality is a mere
figment of thought it becomes subjected
in the bad sense of subjectivity all
right
he says it's a pure abstraction without
that internal division which would be
nothing else but the content if there
isn't a dialectical relationship between
the form and the content between the in
halt right and the the structure the the
orientation then we're losing out
something that we were just playing with
abstraction for figments of our own
imagination this would be an indeed
would handle that at many points in
other works calls a philosophy the
understanding as opposed to a philosophy
of the concept now on the other hand as
he goes ahead and tells us he says since
they are laws of pure thought and pure
thought is intrinsically universal so if
we're no longer just dealing with the
individual but we're thinking in terms
of the universal then and that means
that law actually does encompass all
reality this is the idealism right that
reason observing reason and reason
itself is bringing to the world the
Hegel says that it continues all being
and they're there in all reality so what
does that mean these laws are absolute
notions and are inseparably the
essential principles both of for
and stays so both of the form and of the
content so if that's the case then these
are sort of bound together and no longer
simply oppose the form receives it you
know internal division within it the law
has extended into the content
it's almost pretty good doesn't that so
you know somebody says since imminent
self moving universality is a sundered
simple notion the latter thus has in
itself a content but not just any
content Hegel says this is the content
that has all content so what did it what
we're doing when we're trying to
understand these laws of thought we're
not just trying to understand how the
human beings think we're trying to
understand how many human beings
interact with reality otherwise would be
purely formal right and wouldn't help us
out in relation to reality so we have to
encompass all reality to do that which
means that the content has to be
everything the the totality of the
system you could say right so he says is
all content not only as such was being
as a content which is neither in a
contradiction with the form nor is
separated from it rather it is
essentially the form itself for the
latter is nothing else but the universal
dividing itself in just pure moments how
do we indeed grasp content we grasp
content through form we don't grasp it
as totally divorced from form now but we
may do that when we were doing exercises
like mind mapping and try to figure out
where the things fit in with each other
we're going to brainstorm and then try
to you know arrange them into church
that's a very very artificial sort of
process from the Hegelian perspective
when we're really looking at not only
the world but
introspectively our own minds the form
itself is is self dividing the content
itself is already connected with four
but the way in which this for more
content presents itself to observation
quoi observation gives it the character
of something found something that is
given that is a Content that merely is
it becomes a quiescent being of
relations of multitude of detached
necessities which as in and for
themselves a fixed content are supposed
to have truth in their determinate nests
thus are in fact withdrawn from the form
this absolute truth of fixed determinate
misses or a number of different laws
contradicts however the unity of
self-consciousness or thought and form
in general what is asserted to be a
fixed law that is in itself constant can
only be a moment of the unity which is
reflected into itself can only appear as
a vanishing magnitude but torn out of
this context of movement in the course
of considering them and represented
separately it is not content that they
lack for they possess a definite content
but rather form which is their essence
in point of fact these laws are not the
truth of thought not because they are
supposed to be merely formal and to
possess no content but rather for the
opposite reason that is that they are
supposed in their determinate Nisour
just as a content from which form has
been removed to rank as something
absolute either truth is vanishing
moments in the unity of thought they
would have to be taken as a knowing or
as a movement of thoughts but not as
laws of being but observing is not
knowing itself and is ignorant of it it
converts its own nature into the form of
being that is it grasps its negativity
only as laws of knowing it is sufficient
here to have pointed out the invalidity
of the so called laws of thought from
the general nature of the case the more
precise development belongs to
speculative philosophy in which they
show themselves to be with the are in
truth that is single vanishing moments
whose truth is only the whole movement
of thought that is knowing itself
here in paragraph 300 Hegel is telling
us something that if you really think
out its implications at this point it is
quite extraordinary
he is grappling still with this notion
of laws of thought or this idea of laws
of thought that we would someone derive
from observation observation of self
consciousness by self consciousness now
at this point of course taken up into
the higher your stall of Reason which
attempts to find laws for things no
longer just to live and find its meaning
in the world the way previous shapes of
self-consciousness did have been in that
section and what he says is that
observation is trying to grasp this
relationship between form and content
but it's finding it as something merely
given something that has found the
content that merely is given by what
given by reality reality here is the
other that is attempted that being
attempted to be grasped by the observing
consciousness which is also an other to
itself as we found in the self
consciousness section a lot of stuff
going on behind the scene in this
section if we if we draw it out so what
is Hegel have to tell us about this
relationship between form and content
that it's trying to get to he says
because it finds it merely has something
given it finds it as a content that
merely is it becomes a quiescent being
of relations the restful being of
relations it's lost its dinah dinah
mississippi we can say right it is a
multitude of detached necessities that
goes way a little bit further so
relations things are still connected
detached necessities means that these
things are supposed to have some sort of
necessity in and of themselves that can
be totally separated totally abstracted
from all the other necessities within
system within the world within
consciousness within the field of
thought that's going to present a major
problem in just a moment but let's go on
so he says he finds a multitude of
detachment ease and he says that these
are that these in and for themselves are
fixed contents in the previous paragraph
which I have a form now we're saying
that they have fixed contents and what
do we mean by this well think about when
people try to articulate it will stick
just with the laws of thought in this
case when they're teaching you something
out of a textbook about psychology or
about economics or about really anything
having to do with the human marketing is
a great example of this as well
self-help books in certain ways I'm
going to teach you the eight principles
of how people act well what you're doing
there is you're teaching content and
you're teaching it as sort of detached
from the other contents what media is
what connects contents with each other
they just push it into each other and
bleed into each other don't actually
form there has to be structure there and
for Hegel that structure cannot itself
simply be just yet another content
something inert it's gonna have to be
something dynamic that's what's been
left out and so many accounts so what
are we after in this we're trying to
attain to the law the overarching law
for self consciousness but what he says
is this absolute truth of fixed
determinate missus yields us laws in the
plural right he says a number of
different laws which unfortunately
though contradicts the unity of
self-consciousness we want there to be a
law a way of understanding things any
dynamic intelligibility to all of this
but instead what we're getting are a
whole bunch of laws and we already know
where that's going right because we've
been through the force in the
understanding section where if there's a
multiplicity of law
you know you want to say well how are
these actually connected with each other
insofar as they deal with content they
start to seem less and less like actual
laws and the laws themselves become
content they lose the the sense of
movements there are no longer dynamic
there are no longer expressions of
freedom the free notion that we talked
about that's a problem you might say if
we want to use this language of object
that the more that we objectify the laws
about human beings the less they
actually apply to real living human
beings including the ones that are
making the laws which is an interesting
issue which he's been talking about
further in paragraphs yet to come so he
goes on he says what is a certain to be
a fixed law that is in itself constant
can only be a moment of the unity which
isn't reflected into itself
can only appear as a vanishing magnitude
what is all that that Hegel talks about
vanishing magnitude is an awful lot
right what does he mean by that what
he's saying is that if we've got a
plurality of laws they can really only
make sense out of what it is that
they're attempting to articulate
attempting to formulate and
intelligibility for for the the thinking
subject if they somehow connect up with
each other you know no one single one of
them is the capital T law but rather
they are relativized you might say in in
relation to each other and in relation
to the thinking human being
so Hegel says torn out of this context
of movement in the course of considering
these laws of represented separately
it's not actually content that they lack
really they've got too much content
because all they have is content what's
happened on the other hand is they have
lost the form why they lost form it
doesn't mean they have no articulation
no structure you don't have any bullet
points you know you don't have any pair
paragraph B or anything like that no
what he means there is they've lost any
sort of dynamic movement that would bake
them something that has to do with
self-consciousness and become strong
self-consciousness they are a product
which no longer exemplifies the process
you might say so he goes I'm sensible in
point of fact these laws are not the
truth of thought oh there's a problem
there right we want them to be the truth
of thought not because they're supposed
to be merely formal and possess no
content like what was said in the last
paragraph but for the exact opposite
reason he says that they're supposed to
they're determining this or just as a
Content from which form has been removed
to rank as something absolute now can
consciousness accept that that means
consciousness not only begins with
something that is given sort of you know
something that's not only you might say
heterogeneous to it but heteronomous if
we want to use a Content formulation if
we're talking about free self
consciousness free self consciousness in
giving itself laws has to be able to
work with those laws to make sense of
things it cannot accept the law simply
ask something coming from above or from
below or from that stuff over there or
perhaps even from another self
consciousness this is a dynamic that
we're still going to have to explore so
this plurality of laws is very
problematic this this fact that they are
just content that is being treated in
that salute very problematic he goes on
and he says in their truth his vanishing
moments in the unity of thought that
would have to be taken as a knowing or a
woman of thought but not as laws of
being then he says something really
interesting here officer observing is
not knowing itself it is ignorant of it
some observation is not yet self
knowledge in this case more has to be
developed observation is attempting to
make sense out of all of this
and it's going to produce what are going
to be postulated as laws of being or
laws of knowing that don't actually turn
out to be such he says it converts its
own nature into the form of being it
treats itself as an object in effect
consciousness it grasps its negativity
only has laws of knowing or put it
another way
it does add ISTA balaji and write books
of epistemology as the prologue to doing
philosophy not only the way they count
did but also the way that hume did the
way that decart did the way they locked
it the way that even hops did Hegel is
reacting against something
prototypically modern here isn't he this
is a quite an interesting development
you have to read into this to see that
that going up so he goes on when he says
it's sufficient here to pointed out the
invalidity of the so-called laws of
thought from the general nature case the
more precise development belongs to
speculative philosophy whose speculative
philosophy picking the speculative
philosophy in which they show themselves
to be what they're in truth single
vanishing walnuts whose truth is only
the whole moment of thought knowing
itself where are we made to find this in
the phenomenology what point is he going
to discuss this well the answer is
throughout the entire phenomenology
that's what is going on
the Animus development of you know
consciousness from these smaller lower
less complex less articulate less self
referential stages to more and more
complex stages that can take into
account the totality more and more as we
go up
this negative unity of thought is for
itself or rather it is being for its own
self the principle of individuality and
in its activity is active consciousness
consequently the observing consciousness
will by the nature of the case be led
towards this as the actuality of those
laws since this connection is not
explicit for the observing consciousness
it supposes that thought in its laws
remains over on one side and that on the
other side it obtains another being and
what is now an object for it that is the
active consciousness which is for itself
in such a way that it supersedes other
Ness and in this intuition of itself as
the negative has its actuality
in this short paragraph number 301
Hingle is setting up a duality that he's
going to exploit really throughout the
rest of this section in the paragraphs
yet to come so he talks about the
negative unity of thought being for
itself and then says that it's actually
being for its own self that is firs
exempt design and we'll talk a little
bit more about the implications of that
in a moment
what's really important here is that
through this paragraph that as it flows
through he's setting up something that
observing consciousness is splitting its
field into you might say so on one side
we have thought in its laws the laws of
thought that we've been looking for up
until this point you know although he
doesn't say this this is really the side
of the universal is is you've been
contrasting the universal against the
individual here on the other side and
this is what he talks about much more in
this paragraph we have the active
consciousness we have consciousness no
longer merely as observing but
consciousness as realizing its own
involvement in this and the paragraphs
that are yet to come we're going to see
quite a lot of reflective referentiality
of consciousness being aware of its own
situation at least to some degree so he
talks about this in terms of being the
actuality of the principle of
individuality remember that this section
is about self consciousness grasping
itself in terms of not only its
universality that's also its actuality
it's being as as something that can be
observed something that can be
registered here's where Hegel talks
about it as being being for its own self
for his itself that no longer being for
self but being for its own self being
zealous being you know sort of reflexive
relation of when we talk about identity
we don't mean identity as just logical
identities
be but rather it realizes itself as
identical with itself and again the
implications of this are yet to be drawn
out so he says observing consciousness
is going to be led towards this as the
actuality of the laws the laws don't
stand by themselves the law does make
sense insofar as they are being referred
to and also applied to some sort of
individuality so we've got once again
the universal on one side and the
individual on the other side and the
question is where we're going to go from
here
so he's laid out this this sort of
bifurcation and he says the act of
consciousness is for itself in such a
way that it supersedes other Ness and in
this intuition of itself as the negative
has its actuality what is its other
nacelles within its own self but another
way of thinking of its other is that of
thought in general the individual is
opposed in a certain way to the
universal or the general and we're going
to see how this plays itself out as I
said in the paragraphs yet to come
you